welcome back so we're let's see we're on
problem number
15 boy this s.a.t can be tiring
i know you probably rolled your eyes
when i said that because you're the one
that has to take it not me anyway number
15. the graph above shows and this is on
page 399. it shows a lena height in
inches so the graph looks like this
so
this is
looks like let's see this is one this is
the
other and then i'll draw the rest i have
to draw these fancy lines you get the
point so this is her age
and they do it at
6
8
10
and 12
and then when she's six
she is 45 inches this is in inches so
it's six she's at 45
at eight
at eight she's at
50.
at 10
she's at 55 oh no a little less than 50
well this is like at fit on the graph it
looks like 55
and the way they draw it it's like a
little bit lower than 55 so 10 it's like
a little bit lower than 55 on the graph
and then at 12 she's right at 60.
so 12 she's right at 60.
12 she's right at 60. and then they draw
you know they draw a line connecting all
of them so it looks something like this
so the line looks like this like this
like this nothing fancy
and it says
elena's height at age 12 was what
percent greater than a height at age
six so when she is 12 age
height
height
so at age 12 she's what
at age 12 she's 60 centimeters we just
that's this point right 60.
and at age six
at age six she's what 45 centimeters
right age 6 45
45. so this question is really
so there we're going to make sure that
we're reading elena's height at the age
of 12 was what percent greater than our
height at the age of six so they're
really saying 60 is what percent greater
than
45.
and so
i actually do this all the time in my
job i work at a hedge fund but this is
what i do all the time and a really
quick and dirty way of doing this you
would literally say well this is the
same thing as
60 divided by 45
minus 1
to get either a percentage because
well i i don't want to confuse you too
much but 60 divided by 45 would tell you
what percentage 60 is of 45
right
so 60 divided by 45 is what
it's
one point and one and fifteen
forty-fifths or one point three three
three three three right
i think you can confirm that so that
equals 1.333333
or 60
60
is
133 percent
of
45
right
so we can make all of these statements
60 over 45 that's the percent that 60 is
of 45 that's 1.33333 keeps repeating
right repeating
but they want to know what percent
greater
than our height at 86
so 60 is 133
percent of 45.
this is the same thing as saying that 60
is 33 percent
greater
than 45.
hopefully you understand what i'm saying
100 saying some one thing is 133 of
another thing is the same thing as
saying that this first thing is 33
percent greater than 45
or we could say that you know saying
something 133
percent
is equal to 33 percent
more than a hundred percent right
more than a hundred
hope i'm not confusing you
but uh i'm try i try to do this in a
couple of different ways to
help you understand what 33 percent
greater means 33 if one thing if x is 33
greater than y that means x is 133
of y
so they want to know how much greater is
60 than 45 well it's 33 percent greater
33 percent greater and so the answer is
c 33 and one-third because it's
repeating 33.
next problem
image clear image
all right now this this looks fun
so we have
this cylinder looking thing
let me see how well i can draw a
cylinder
well
my cylinder is going to be a little
tilted but you get the point i should
have drawn these vertical lines first
so
this is the cylinder
so that's the cylinder and they're
saying that
if we it's on the base of the cylinder
we have this line
line x
or this distance x goes to the center
this is essentially the center of the
cylinder and then let me draw it in a
more muted color to show that it's in
the inside and this is kind of the
height of the cylinder goes to
goes to the top
but they're essentially asking
saying which of the following and they
give you a bunch of choices has this
has the same volume as a cylinder shown
with radius x and height 2x so they're
saying
this is x
that's x and this is 2x
so before figuring out which of these
choices has the same volume as this
thing let's figure out what the volume
of this thing is
well the way i i you don't have to if
you know the area of a circle you
essentially know the volume of a
cylinder because it's really the area of
one of you know you can kind of figure
out the area of this base and then just
multiply it times the height right
multiply it times this third dimension
the height so what's the area of this
base
so volume
is equal to area of the base which is pi
times the radius squared so that's pi x
squared
pi
x squared and we're going to multiply
that times the height
times this times 2x
right
times 2x
so the volume of this is equal to
2x times this you get 2
pi
x to the third right because it's x to
the first add the exponents
so volume is 2 pi x to the third we know
the volume of our cylinder so let's see
what of the what these other choices are
so choice a
says a cylinder with radius 2x and
height x
so radius is equal to 2x and the height
is equal to
x so what would this be
the area the volume would be it would be
this times pi
this squared times pi times this right
because we take the area of the base
so the area of the base would be what it
would be
pi
times 2 x
squared and then we multiply that times
the height
and this equals i can already tell you
this isn't going to be right because
we're going to get a 4 in here this oh
this is x right the height is x
so this will get 4
pi
x to the third if you multiply it out so
that's not it
b
a cylinder with radius 2 pi
radius is equal to 2 pi x
and height is equal to x
and i can already tell you this is going
to be it because we're going to get
something with a pi squared in it right
because you take the area you take the
area of the base you get
you get
well the volume will just be pi times
2 pi
x squared times x right times and we're
going to get 4 pi squared and
and then you're going to have another pi
and 4 pi cubed it's not going to be the
same thing as this
choice c
a cube with edge 2x
well this is easy if if a cube has side
2x its volume is just that side cubed
right so volume would be 2x
to the third and that equals 8 x cubed
that's definitely not right
d
a cube with edge 2 pi x
so same thing the volume for this cube
would be 2 pi x
to the third and this is going to be
what 8 pi to the third x to the third
once again not right
so
assuming i haven't done anything wrong
yet it's probably going to be choice e
but let's confirm
choice e
a rectangular solid with the dimensions
ah let's see this looks very suspicious
so let me draw the rectangular solid
a rectangular solid
with the dimensions
x
2 x
and pi x
so we just multiply with times height
times depth so
2x so it's x times 2x times pi x you
would get 2 pi x cubed 2 pi
x cubed
and the answer is
e
very good
and you could do that faster just kind
of like inspecting some of these earlier
ones anyway i'll see in the next video